[Music]
hello everyone I'm Jim Dennis Porsche
and this is yours choice we're going to
watch very interesting games like
everyone else here I'm interesting to
see what we have so let's start with
this game between F gar and simin was
named to Nana Nana 96 let's see okay II
for that seems like a legal move
c5 Bishop c4 hmm is there any fans out
there for Bishop c4 yeah not many fans
and it doesn't include me the problem is
not the move that black male makes 'if
I've what's wrong with a 5 yes yeah
leaves a hole on d5 and that was exactly
the point of Bishop c4 awaiting this
move which is a really bad move so
instead what should black try to do yes
Archer yeah ii 6 try to blockade this
bishops diagonal and potentially play d5
hmm like might even consider playing a6
castle and b5 and just chase chasing the
bishop away and if he is nice enough or
she's nice enough to play Bishop b3 then
we just capture it with c4 so Simon with
a lot of numbers play d5 and
why play of Queen f3 I'm again not a
great fan of this move but it's not as
terrible this time can anyone help me
why isn't it's so bad this time
yes yeah it's not terrible there because
it's not that it'd be blockaded but it
does put some pressure on the d5 square
and eventually the knight can find the
Knights nice spot on g3 let's see if
that actually happens Knight of 6 Knight
c3 g6
well this g6 move I don't like because
in general fianchetto is are nice but
they do weaken the kingside position a
little bit and black already has a lot
of weaknesses in the center so Knight d5
that was unnecessary unnecessary d3
would have been better like d5 Bishop g7
correct developed castle as quickly as
you can D 3 D 6 and D 6 was not good he
should have taken on d5 Bishop takes d5
and castles and this doesn't look like
much of a fun for black because this
Bishop on g7 is horrible and this bishop
on d5 is beautiful it's the beauty and
the beast' again so t 3 d6 h3 mm-hmm can
we find a better move than h3
the guy with the glasses what could be
better than the move h 392 or or what
else can
why put some pressure on flex position
Bishop g5 yes thank you and now it will
be pretty hard to move even though it's
not losing yet for black you can still
play 97 but you can feel the discomfort
already for it to black side each three
castles 92 there should be six not ec3
just defending this d5 square forever
Knights e6 castles rugby eight
94 was needed already weird Bishop g5
Knight d4 Queen g3 thank God that night
is on c3 because otherwise there'll be
an ite to check Knight take c2 so black
took upon but does that solve all his
problems in this position yes why not
mm-hmm why does control all of these
white squares especially that d5 square
but there's one big issue and that's
called that big huge pen along the h4 d
a diagonal so rooks e 194 Queen h4 we
should be five ninety five ninety to
check engage one night take c1 and now I
think this is a critical position I
don't know what what actually played
here and but I don't know because we're
at a dilemma
should we start taking everything he
gives us or should we take back on c1
yeah
yeah so let's see what happened Bishop
f6 but I agree we should just take on c1
cuz our pen is eternal
he can't move this Knight Bishop
combination plus the extra Queen on h4
makes it sure that we're winning here
so the Queen can't move really because
we'll take the check and we'll soon mate
with Queen age six Queen g7 in anyways
if he can't stop the idea of taking on
f6 he's just that lost but F guard took
on f6 takes takes King g7 and now again
questions how should we continue mm-hmm
okay Queen takes h7 as you just told us
to play is good I think Cain takes f6
just as played here and how should we
continue now why not take on you said f4
why not just take on c1 mm-hmm okay he
took on c1
so f4 it's a very interesting idea
because all of our pieces are attacking
and this night is not really doing
anything so for example if not goes to
e2 we can take on e5
if King g7 then we just checked me just
quite a nice checkmate with all the
black pieces on developed otherwise this
looks fairly dangerous for black I'm I
don't really trust the idea of taking on
e5 when I'm sure I'm not the only one
so anyways f4 was a real idea here to
play and as you just said keeping the
momentum was an idea here so that's why
it's an important thing to stop before
you take pieces don't automatically take
everything that's in your way rook takes
c1 okay Jade which unfortunately doesn't
when the Queen but loses the f7 pawn in
g5 Queen f3 97 king g1 a little bit
mysterious
maybe Queen g3 immediately would have
been better in g1 we got faith in G 3
can you have sex
hmm
how would you how would you evaluate
this position I wonder
we do have an extremely strong bishop on
c4 an active queen but does rooks are
getting connected black seems to get
gotten out of trouble right now so it's
not entirely clear for me what's the
situation but what does the audience
think yeah triple zeros why hmm so the
audience said it's triple zeros but I I
heard the sarcastic laugh what was your
opinion
hmm so the other opinion is opinion is
that black is actually slightly better I
think
paradoxically I think both is close to
the truth because white is really active
but at the moment black has a slight
material advantage so I could see that
in the long term it could favor black
what white is really active now right so
f4 takes green takes F for King g7 g v
queen d8 black is aggressively looking
for the idea of exchanging Queens
green G for green f6 in d7 check rook f7
I don't think Brooke f7 was necessary
right yeah
obviously we kept something was a
terrible move King gate six would have
been better and would we still evaluate
this position around equal 0.14 white
hmm well you do get the pawn but
actually if you take I can attack your
pawn let's say you take I take on b2 and
then I'm really dangerous so rook f1
okay but then I'll have Queen g5 ideas
this will get very dangerous yeah so
yeah white needs to tread carefully here
I'm not sure that it's terrible for
white but but it's slightly worse
definitely worse here ook f7 wasn't the
best idea
takes Queen takes and obviously here
white is just totally when I mean takes
d6 Queen takes a two
how should you continue here for white
should we take on c5 yeah exactly Queen
e5 would be very precise here because as
you said if King aged seven then rook
takes c5 and now it's a much much more
favorable situation for white then if we
take immediately as the rook swings to
c7 with decisive threats and the Queen
loves being centralizes it can defend
our own King while also harassing the
black king so Queen takes e5 yeah Queen
e5 was a better move me take c5 pin
takes me to check King f6 check in these
six King g5 and clinging f6 mate well a
topsy-turvy game but an entertaining one
and actually white did find a clear-cut
way how to play the position although he
was a little bit imprecise and actually
gaining the decisive advantage alright
let's move to game two
so this game was sent by Fonseca from
Brazil and he's playing black let's see
how it go efore c5 what opening is this
it's a Sicilian it's a Fischer favorite
yes this is obviously the night off so
white played a move that is really rare
these days but played by Judit Polgar
and i think it may be even they're
Christians and and recently Nakamura
beat and VL with this Bishop d3 move
honestly it's quite passive and not
because of e5 because if black to play
e5 then I can jump to e 2 and eventually
to g3 and that was the game so if a guy
I don't think is the critical move in
this position but black played b5 which
i think is inaccurate because whenever
black plays b5 way too early
my can punish that any ideas how how can
we punish this early b5 move in denied
ourf so a4
before let's be more aggressive we're
playing against the neither if we must
be aggressive how can we be more
aggressive than Knights ee - yeah r95 in
obviously who found the idea of Knight
d5 was none other than Bobby Fischer
because when he played h3 and he mented
this system his opponent played b5 and
then he has said this move of Knight d5
already kind of pinpointing the
weaknesses around the black queen side
all right so Bishop d3 b5 and similarly
in this situation you can also play
Knight d5 here the point is if black
takes on d5 e takes black already cannot
really move the e pawn and also Bishop
e7 can be punished by this c4 move and
takes takes and black is really passive
in these type of positions or we can do
it with a 4b 495 and if ecigs and we
just take and black pieces won't be
coordinated enough so white is clearly
better
so b 583 if V is sometimes good but here
might need it to be more aggressive for
example black could have played with g6
which is the usual plan and Bishop g7
and then this Bishop on d3 would be
rather passive so b5 a3 we should be 7
Castle and now 97 h3 and g6 nice little
double fianchetto by black how can white
try to play against this system
have any of you seen this position
before on which side will what white
will play eventually
on the kingside obviously because most
of the pieces are kind of staring at the
black king
so why play tonight at 3:00 but that's
kind of against his own play night of
three just slows down any kind of ideas
of mating black so white needs to find a
different plan
yes
yeah f4 is pretty good although you have
to be varied that ping b6 can be a
trouble
we do have Bishop III but if we miss the
screen b6 idea of we might get into big
troubles but here is fine and Bishop g7
now here there is a typical idea that
you can use to put more pressure on the
e5 + f5 square this is a very useful
move to remember if you're playing the
white side you might encounter these
position in Parkes and modern defences
so the knight on d4 is a little bit
loose right so how can we improve our
piece so it'll be actually useful in
this position yeah
yes
neither three prepares this idea of e5
which is obviously very edgy and white
usually only plays it if it works
otherwise mine might just go Queenie one
let's say rook c8 Queen h4 means c7 and
f5 and what is White's plan after f5 can
someone help me with that yeah yeah to
play knight say Knight c5 Bishop h6 and
just to try attack with Knight g5 and
you can soon see that this can actually
turn out to be fairly decisive because
what's coming up next is taking on g7
taking on g6 ok let's play random move
for black Lance say like rook e8 then
white can take take F takes F takes and
rook takes f6 is already kind of
decisive because if rook takes then we
just take on 87 and c7 Queen drops and
if the King takes how can we win
well we can play rook f1 check first or
we can just take take on eight seven and
just be a pawn up so this is actually a
very very poisonous idea for white to
play Knight f3 Queen e1 Queen h4 so
usually black tries to stay on this
diagonal with the black Queen so you can
try to exchange the Queen's and this
will turn into a very wild tactical game
later on if Y plays this FF for Knight
f3 plan now white missed his chance and
most probably didn't know that he should
play that way and played Knight f3
instead which is not good because
there's no plan associated with this
move Bishop g7 rook e1 what else can I
try to do in this position okay we play
Knight f3 but then we have to come up
with a different plan than so there's no
more f4 idea here what else can we try
to do here
he played rookie 1 but he could have
gone Bishop III castles Queen d2
interact exchange that not a bishop on
g7 and I'm not saying why it is better
but why it is in the game so rook e1
castle not Age 2 and maybe the other
plan that white often plays with reverse
colors in the English system is like
Bishop f1 and trying to play Knight d5
or Bishop g5 although Bishop g5 would
invite rook takes c3 sacrifices here
castles night h2 95 a typical very
strong move I like this move by black
because as soon as white moves away to
worse place black activates his knights
and puts it in a central very active
spot on e5 at 490 XD 3c takes the 397 so
how can we sum up the situation who's
better who has a clear-cut plan who
doesn't yeah yeah yeah as you say white
really doesn't have a plan here
black indeed has the bishop pair and a
slight advantage you don't necessarily
need to open up the position with f5
will do it if we feel it's the right
time
92 rook c8 Bishop e3 and that was upon
okay to Bishop g7 but to be honest max
position is very comfortable and with
correct play black should be able to
build on his advantage of bishop pair
and in general more strategically better
position we should be three takes Bishop
g7 and I g3 rook II a
rook e8 I don't really understand what
else could black try to play here or try
to play for
yeah
h 5 h 4 is an interesting idea but
you're kind of helping get giving your
opponent some play he wants to play on
the kingside anyways
where does black have the advantage in
this position yeah on the queenside
so if you have the advantage on one of
the sides you should move more pieces on
that direction mm-hmm perfect that's a
good strategic plan
you could go to c5 as well if you like
you're not on an outpost but I like
Knight b6 as well because you don't
close your book that way and often it's
important to keep your rooks file open
so Knight b6 is perfect and if let's say
Queen f3 then Knight a four and we can
already feel the heat in this position
and for your white because the knight is
landing on c3 and it would be a monster
and we won't have real time to get rid
of it and black might even consider
rolling all those pawns with a 5 B 4 and
with the help of that night it'll soon
be a win so I think as you said Knight
b6 would be stronger stronger than rook
e8 h4 h5 h5 is good he just wants to
stop the idea of h4 h5 it's a good idea
to stop your opponents from having a
good plan f5 rook f8 that's an okay move
but not great 1 F 2 X Queen b3 King h7
Bishop f6 Bishop g5 95 a good move why
is 95 a good move here
yeah yeah so black is trading off the
best pieces of white and also it's a
good thing to exchange pieces when your
opponent is down material so Bishop
takes f6 Knight a 3G takes after II
broke up six rook f1 Queen d7 eyeing
this age three square it defends though
II five why is this e five move good
I like the c5 move yeah yeah so it nails
down White's position also it puts these
pawns on black squares so it helps our
Bishop to move more easily
okay to see f8 Queen c3 and now the
bishop arrives with deadly threats on h3
rook age one Queen f7 back Bishop g4
nice tactical idea because white can't
take because of rook f2 takes green
takes f2 and black is just totally
winning here fade Bishop g4 so after
Bishop g4 white resign this was in a
very good game played by white I mean
this was a very good game played by
black and even though b5 in the opening
was a little bit suspicious it was a
good display of harmonic harmonic pace
piece played by black which eventually
just proved far stronger than whites
play it's a good it was a good game by
black
yeah now let's take a look at this game
d4 d5 c4 d takes what can what is the
name of this opening yes means gambit
accepted Caruana just started playing
this recently night a3 Bishop e6 is
Bishop e6 a brilliant move in this
position no not really this Bishop is
just blockading this pawn so it will be
very difficult to to actually develop
for black III knight c6 a very weird
move c6 would be better with the idea of
playing b5 and trying to hold to the
trying to keep that c4 pawn knight c6 92
b5 my place Bishop b2 here what else
could we play in this position for white
what comes to mind in these positions
yeah
if our is one idea but there's one move
that is very very strong in these
particular Queens gambit accepted and
these sacrificed pawn positions yeah
how can you break up this these spawns
how can we undermine them yeah b3 and
actually b3 this is the basic idea of
the d4 variations this b3 move because
if C takes b3 we take on b5 first and
then we have an overwhelming positional
advantage because this D for III f2 pawn
chain is just a waste appear to black
structure like does have the c3 move now
but we need not fear that when play
Knight e4 even if he defends it we can
undermine his position with a 3 and even
if that wouldn't work we'll have an
active night on c5 and it's way enough
compensation white is just clearly
better here this is an important thing
to remember this b3 move this should be
2 it's a fine move Bishop g4 Castle II 6
very good decision by black like just
decides that it is time to develop
pieces regardless what he'd done with
his Center before h3 Bishop f3 not a
good idea because the white squares are
already very weak takes takes Queen d7
and here comes the move that we've been
talking about
Oh b3 very good idea c3 the same thing
Knight e4 and every bits and pieces
everything is kind of weak around blacks
position and after a3 a5 doesn't even
work because it takes before there's no
a takes before because the rook is
hanging so black needs to take with the
bishop and after Queen c2 will take back
the pawn and will have just a superior
position
see takes night xb3 Ruby ate Bishop d2
a6
all very well played here how should we
continue here if you're white what moves
spring to mind in these positions for
white
first let's detect the weaknesses there
are blacks weaknesses in this position
yeah he's exposed King yes yeah so if we
can pinpoint that this knight on c6 is a
little bit loose yeah rook c1 is a great
move
simple chess that's all we need simple
chess now I can't pinpoint how bad legs
position is if black will play the
natural night e7 move then we just rawr
jump to c5 and put pressure on blacks
position immediately and if black has to
play Queen c8 that's the beginning of
the end we know that this is not going
to end well for black no way so I think
we'll see one is a good move but he
played Knight c5 but I have my doubts
about this move Knight c5 what's the
problem with Knight c5 yep yeah black
can take it takes and the fact that the
let black exchange your passive piece on
f8 is not good and also the fact that
after we took on c5 we just closed this
very weak see line which we would have
used for great effect of the rook c1
which I very much like tonight c5 takes
Knight e5 well black should have
developed his pieces to e7 and
that would have been great so 95 Bishop
b4 Knight f3 beam takes f3 Knight f6
it's a little bit dubious I think Knight
a 7 is better trying to protect the c6
square if Blackman actually manages to
build a blockade here and manages to
castle as well black will be fine and
might even be better because of the
extra poem so Knight f6 what should we
play here with white black just allowed
us to do something that he really
shouldn't have and I might I think
should live the moment and find this
move yes yes c6 and more than likely
White's position is near winning because
black is not going to Castle in the near
future and even let's say Queen d5 and
we wouldn't play Queen g3 but look FD 1
the simple move will still have like a
huge advantage because he can't castle
and in the long run we can undermine
blacks position with a 4 and a takes b5
so root d1 queen e7 root D 295 really
unnecessary move that could have just
Castle then I'm sure black is much much
better here also because this Bishop is
just terrible
now we had the chance to make it a
beautiful piece after c6 few moves ago
here this Bishop would work perfectly
and will have a brilliant position but
after rook d1 Queen d7 c6 is no longer
possible because of Queen takes before
and after let's say Brooke d2 castles
black is just much better and this
Bishop is just eyeing upon which really
does nothing so Knight d5 wasn't great
also Queen c6 check
should have been played for better or
worse rook D 295 a3 it's an okay move
Knight takes a takes and c6 well this
move is not good obviously it's a very
bad move black devil it needs to castle
here and back is up a pawn but why does
have the open D line so it's not that
easy at black might be slightly slightly
better but if you have the D line in
these rook rook and queen and games
what has chances to hold especially that
this a sex pun is a little bit loose and
week so take c6 not a good move rook
Levon not a good one we need to take on
c6 rugby one castle takes eight six BAM
taking them a six pawn Queen c7 c6 will
be six not a good move and especially if
you have a protected see palm try not to
move it until you're sure you're not
gonna lose it because if you're beep on
just creates you this protected pawn you
can use this 50 moves later as well so
this is kind of an advantage for the
long term so playing c6 now was very bad
idea in this position
rugby 6 would be 17 takes c6 and
suddenly black is fine again
Queen a7r okay six Queen b7 takes b7
well black
I don't think needed to take on b7 in
fact bouquet 6 was not really needed in
any ways it could be a little bit
uncomfortable because of these 7th
ranked pieces of white but it should be
fine for black okay six Queen b6 takes
okay - Luke takes b5 so after some play
we've reached this endgame and this
should be pretty much winning for white
g5
trying to create a loft for the Kings
rook c5 beat so is there any move that
could be potentially better than rook c5
yeah rook v1 just trying to have a pond
behind the pawn
yes have the rook behind the pond yes
rook c5 Ruby to b5 but this is also a
good plan because the bat White's rooks
are very active on the C and D files so
this could work as well f5 or the route
Oh on a second thought would be a second
thought Ruby eight could be a problem
okay f5 another a good move rook d6 and
after this this is just winning cuz the
b-pawn is just promoting in general if
you have end games try not to push all
of your pawns because they'll get weak
and black should have just tried tried
to wait play either King g7 or Ruby
eight kind of just waiting for whites to
show his cards try to win the position
if you push too many of your pawns you
might too many weaknesses and you lose
because of them you might not lose
necessarily because of the beep on but
because of your pawn weaknesses route d6
we have six b6f for Luke c8 can get
seven check b7 and actually that is the
reason why black is losing because he
pushed his F pawn otherwise they
wouldn't have been these rooks see a
troop d7 and b7 moves which just win and
as the white pawn on b7 is cleaning this
position is just dead lost for him black
and after Ruby g8 black resigned
so in general tried to develop first try
to castle and don't get too greedy and
hold to see four pawns cuz that just
don't work out well yes
the last game this was sent by Hofer in
he was black b3
a Larsen favorite and also a rapport
favorite not a terribly impressive move
but it's playable he 5 Bishop b2 96
I think the Larsen system the Larsen
variation yes III Knight f6 Bishop b5
and here comes an Eric Rosen suggestion
which was efore I guess the idea is to
pin down White's position and even if Y
decides to exchange down that pawn it'll
slow down right a little bit and black
will get a normal position Bishop e7 or
Bishop b4 check efore so I played 92 d5
Castle Bishop d6 d3 and this position
seems all normal and wonderful for white
but if they're familiar with some ideas
in these positions why it might actually
be in real trouble already
why is white and big trouble
yes hmm what yeah the Greek gift works
so why please King gauge one but we also
always have to check how good is it
so King takes h2 Nagi for check it's
important to start with the night check
if he goes back to G 1 green age 4 and
now we have this mate idea on Queen h2
the only move is rook e1 but then we
just take check you always have the draw
but obviously who wants a draw when we
can win a queen Knight takes c3 and
double attacking on the Queen and the g2
pawn so this would have been a nice win
but why didn't want any of that engage
one and now black is in a dilemma
whether to retreat with the bishop or
not these are not easy questions because
one of them might be decisive the other
one might just give a little bit of an
advantage for black how should we
continue here yeah
mm-hmm and why would you play Knight g4
why not Bishop d6
good point so nigh g4 is extremely
strong and as you pointed out correctly
if you're going for a plan and if you're
given an option to continue following
your own plan continue with it don't
start changing plans that's when trouble
stirs up Bishop d6 indeed would be just
a slight advantage because even though
white lost this fun it's not the end of
the world yet and also why does have
some developmental advantage on the
Queen side so now g4 was played g3 so
that g4 although very principled is a
little bit risky because y can trap the
bishop on h2 with g3 so how should we
continue now yes h 5 h 4 is an idea but
actually black found a very good idea
here and that's Queen g5 just going and
coming closer to the White King King g2
Queen a5 9 f4 in fact if white will play
something you know she says Knight c3
black already has a decisive tactical
idea here
there are multiple ways to win but
there's one tactical idea that would win
on the spot many ideas how we could win
in this position the point of the whole
thing would be to try to get close to
this king with our queen on g5 hmm some
night sacrifices well some night
sacrifices don't really work at the
moment and also this night is going to
be our helper in the mate what what is
what's your idea how can ya Bishop takes
g3 so if Knight takes then Queen h4
check and then we just made on h2 so
indeed we need that night for the attack
so that's why we wouldn't want to
sacrifice it already and also this piece
on h2 is kind of passive and we would be
happy to exchange it even sacrifices
because it's mostly is in the way the
other wave would be to go queen h5 but
obviously Bishop takes it g3 is just
much much better so ping g5 King g2
Queen a five-night f4 g5 and this g5
move is very reckless I think black
could just play something like Queen g5
but g5 is like a reckless in a very
brave move which actually is very strong
to for example D takes happened but if
Bishop takes a jet then G takes f 4g
takes f4 and now I'd like to ask you
what move will be the winner here and
actually
it is indeed going to be a night move
this time mm-hmm when I take C three
indeed an F takes mm-hmm Ginga mm-hmm if
King G 1 then Queen H two mates King e2
rinji to look after a very very elegant
win so this g5 even I'm not a hundred
percent sure it's perfect because for
example I can try to hold after night
aged five but it's a very nice daring
idea that Hofer played and it's very
tough to face this at the board so D
takes e4 was played Bishop takes aged
eight as proven by Jason is bad because
of this takes takes and night sacrifice
and obviously if the whites pieces will
not survive if even if he takes on h2
because Queen h3 and Quincy to mate okay
so he took on e4 d takes e4 Queen d5 G
takes Bishop takes c6 takes Queen f5
Bishop a5 Bishop h8 well what kind of
was forced to exchange Queens otherwise
black was really close to mating takes
takes and now f3 King gauge 1 and white
plays a brilliant move here I mean black
plays a brilliant move here
that you don't really see in end games
yes castles castles a very nice move to
play on move 17 in the middle of the
endgame Bishop c3 and now he finds
another really nice maneuver which will
seal the deal for the day so black
basically needs one more piece the rook
yes exactly
and if the rook can enter the
battlefield it's going to be a one
battle natty Knight takes f2 would lose
that piece on h2 so but you can bring
that rook over without any blood spilt
they'll be move a rope maneuver that
will just destroy White's position
Rudy six with the idea
look these six indeed and now the brook
enters the fray with the sight of
threats Bishop g7 rogue g6 Bishop f8 but
black is comfortable and just chases
away the bishop on f-89c three King he
ate brocade 691 this Bishop g3 King g1
check and black one because white
resigned
seeing that King gage one fails to
Bishop e5 checked king g1 and takes on
a1 and it's a piece up with an ongoing
attack so these games are pretty nice
especially the last one and the night
off we saw and I think we can learn to
develop our pieces first Castle and then
go pawn hunting later I think that's the
moral of this lesson we had from these
games thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]